i want to ask a question what would you
call it
if someone called for if there was let's
say there's a high profile public figure
who came out and said i will not wait i
demand
that an action be taken which will
result
in the death of hundreds of millions of
people what would
what do you call it when someone when
someone tries to enact a plan that would
kill hundreds of millions of people
excessive like government government
democrat
democrats democrat wait what is
democracy hemicide is uh death by
government
it's the number one leading cause it's
the number one leading cause of death in
human history
so i'm just trying to what's the word
for a person genocide i think is the
word is that it
are you sure you're saying you're saying
greta tuneburg called for genocide
you're talking about killing
hundreds of millions of people yeah yeah
yeah by taking it yeah that would be
generous
so you're saying that greta tuneburg
called for genocide indirectly because i
didn't say that word you did
you see yeah i tricked you but i
wouldn't even say she called it greta
soonberg said we will not wait till
2030.
or should we do not want to wait till
2030 or 2022 we want
now a moratorium on facebook people that
are screaming about
what their goal is i need to scream
about the plan i need to explain this
otherwise
the genocide thing greta tunberg said we
want a moratorium on oil
now we want it done if we stop using oil
our freight the freight lines our trains
the food delivery systems
transporting of emergency medicines all
of this just stops
and immediately overnight you're going
to see riots in the street
from starving people you remember what
happened in in paris
in france when emmanuel macron was like
we're going to put a tax on
patrol you know because we're going
green or whatever and then would they
get like a year and a half of people
rioting
because all of a sudden their gas bill
was too high because they were trying to
tax them to go green
people want to live you know i was
actually surprised to find out that
that people are fond of living yeah
surprising huh so so when the government
comes in and says
we're not just sacrificing your your
quality of life
we're restricting your ability to feed
your family while we fly on private jets
yeah exactly yeah you bring up a very
important point because when you see
the government's response to the climate
crisis it usually means
hurting the average person the middle
class person
the low-class working person they're the
ones that are going to be paying for it
as they literally flying around in their
private jets and don't
give a darn and sometimes even profit
off of this new you know idea or
innovation that's a carbon tax
a tax on your breath attacks on your co2
and i'm like how more ridiculous could
they get i could just see them sitting
around in the table being like we're
just gonna tax them for breathing this
time whoa whoa
you're forgetting the uk yeah they're
gonna tax you and you're gonna need a
license for it
exactly and and it's just like if if you
think
government licensing is going to solve
anything i demand you spend one week at
the dmv
mandatory if you're ever going to
advocate for such a policy
now i i will i will you now i want to
finish this because
you know just recently i made my rv to
be
i made my rv off the grid i installed a
lot of solar panels and i learned
it doesn't matter how many solar panels
you have if you don't have batteries
in them that i could that could actually
save the power and and when you're
talking about the
battery technology it's not there and i
was like wait how many how many pounds
do these things weigh 200 pounds
and i was like you have to factor in
weight especially if you're in an rv
and the battery technology you know you
you would think you would you would
spend some innovation and some
money and some investment and some
technology looking into
making that better but it's not there
yet and educate luke on new better
technology
well i was just reading about uh
graphene batteries we're talking about
superconductors
um i was actually just reading about
condensing graphene or
carbon dioxide into graphene and what
you do is let me i'll read this this is
from digi
design news.com and the title is
researchers develop graphene from carbon
dioxide
um it says that the project endeavors to
synthesize graphene
uh specifically mimicking photosynthesis
by turning carbon dioxide and oxygen
metal-based enzyme ribulose
uh biphosphate carboxylase oxygenase
and um a little bit of carbon dioxide a
little bit too in the wheat
this is a really just confused this is a
really technical article but ultimately
we're going to have to advance our
battery power we should
we have to i want to contain lightning
energy we should be using lightning as
our
power supply the problem is we don't
know the charge of lightning we've got
to pound these batteries with it and
just store it
so the reason i i shouted you out is
graphene is
this this is the we are we are moving
towards really great advancements
in solid state better technologies
graphene based
battery technologies here's the crazy
thing we talked about before i recently
bought
i think i bought like five uh graphene
composite batteries they use lithium ion
technology but there there's like a
lattice of graphene through it
which allows it to charge like the whole
thing it's two and a half cell phone
charges worth of power
charge up in about 10 or 15 minutes so
normally you plug your phone and it
takes 20 30 minutes
now it's half the time cutting edge dude
this is like when we had like 32
kilobyte
computer ram stuff i mean in 10 years
it's going to be
we're going to be able to charge in like
two seconds and we're going to have days
of power
the big problem is batteries
and they're particularly brutal i mean
when if you get a punctured battery and
it blows up on a phone
that's why they they tell you on planes
you can't bring lithium-bat lithium-ion
batteries into planes
and they're brutal for the environment
and lithium-ion batteries are primarily
made of bauxite and bauxite is mined
90 of it in the congo by slave children
and let's be honest about that
yeah right so we're all going to have
electric vehicles joe biden has said
they're all going to have electric
vehicles
well how many more are slave children
are do we need to employ or well that
do you employ slave children i don't
know what the proper term is that right
these are just the real conversations we
have to have about going green
and also china having these rare earth
minerals that they have a monopoly on
but they're also just yesterday
threatened the united states about
setting up an emporium where they won't
be sending it to the united states but
but you know they're not really rare
well they're called right they're called
rare earths but but it's just that
nobody is mining them properly we have
them all in america right but
oh but china can do it so we don't want
to do the labor absolutely so if you
wanted to be really green you would
allow us to mine them combine them here
it would be better for the environment
we would have great standards
can we just get some of these like
environmental leftists to admit
we live in a neo-feudalist system
where people in europe and the united
states get to live off of the slave
labor
of the serfs in the congo mining the
bauxite and one in china this in the
rare earths
one of my most disliked people in in in
alive right now is a guy named tom
steyer who's a billionaire
um a big environmental cause funder
um he vehemently opposes coal in america
goes out of his way to try to shut down
coal mines in america does not want any
more coal
he made billions of dollars off of
investments in coal indonesia
and china so he'll be damned if a guy in
west virginia is going to
going to mine for coal but a
nine-year-old girl in western china
totally cool but don't you get it he's
kicking the ladder down after he made it
to the top of the mountain absolutely
he's like you can't come up here i'm
rich
you're right it it really is a feudal
system to a certain extent look at
darren john carry on his private jet
leonardo dicaprio
john kerry flew in a private jet to pick
up an environmentalism award
and that's like a fire truck on fire i'm
sorry i love that and trust me if i had
married a rich heiress i
too would not sit in the middle seat
between like the nursing mom
and the girthy millennial like i would
much rather
be on a private jet flying yeah i
wouldn't be like ted cruz trying to get
myself bumped up to first class which he
unsuccessfully did
no no no no no i heard he did get it i
heard he did it that's that's the story
that i heard right there but also bill
gates flew to the paris accords in his
private jet yeah
so not many people know that the last uh
big google pre-covered when google had
their big climate uh
um climate change summit in sicily and
something like 147 private jets
flew to it you know prince harry took
one and everyone 147 private jets you
know
flew to the to the climate change summit
you don't i guess you don't jet pool
like a car pool yeah like hey tim i'll
pick you up we'll fly the jets together
some do some do you know it's fun i'll
give you a ride anytime
you know what the meeting was really
about i really doubt they all sat down
and looked at each other and said man
this global warming's a bad thing we got
we got to figure out to save the planet
what they really did was they said we
can't have all these poor people flying
on planes
how do we make sure that we can stay on
our private planes i don't want to lose
my private plane
yeah that's what it is you get everyone
else to sacrifice so you don't have to
yes
and and that's where we are when it
comes to a lot of these green decisions
right
i just want to know who are the people
that are going to die we know who the
people that are going to lose their job
we talk about it well they'll get a
green job in the future okay
if i'm a keystone pipeline worker i've
been now three weeks without a paycheck
so when's my green job coming
uh the future is green i wanted to
expand a little on this battery
conversation there's another article by
wired
are radioactive diamond batteries a cure
for nuclear waste this is a good one you
might want to pull up looks simple well
we have uh there was a big breakthrough
recently on
solid-state battery technology yeah
which apparently would revolutionize
everything it's like higher energy
density so
this stuff takes the spent nuclear rods
from nuclear power plants which normally
we have to store
in like boxes that are just in them for
a thousand years now you
encase them in glass and you use it as a
heat source for
electricity and they last a thousand
years yes it came out
august of 2020. i mean this is literally
here we just need the president or a
system that understands and wants to
push it it's a it's political right
i don't think they're ignorant you you
you no one look
in the world of politics these people
are looking at what's going to get them
elected
nuclear is scary we've already seen the
giant lizard breathing radioactive fire
and
blowing up buildings and now people are
scared that they're going to you know
grow a third eye or whatever and they
think nuclear energy is the apocalypse
nope my understanding is that nobody
died in three mile island no
no one even got a cold chernobyl however
was
failures of the communist party
absolutely and it was a look what
happened with chernobyl was a
complicated but political it was war it
was cold war and the soviets were
rushing full speed
they had a system where people would
like when you live
under under under authoritarianism you
just say whatever you need to say to
survive
and so when they were having more and
more problems and people are like yeah
everything's fine everything's fine
and that's what they kept doing and then
we got you know it got really bad the
whole thing went up and there's a lot of
problems there
don't get me wrong that's scary that's a
that's a major crisis but hold on
what's worse all of the nuclear energy
disasters we've seen so far
or all of the oil spills deep water
horizon
the oil sticks and the damage at its
cost the dead zones it creates in the
oceans
look i think fossil fuels are important
and and i think the challenge right now
is that we have
you know we're 7.8 billion people we're
trying to make sure they don't die
because we want them to live but while
recognizing it takes a lot of energy
to make sure these people are getting
food they're getting heat some people
don't have food or heat
yeah you know and and we actually try to
subsidize that to help them because we
don't want people to die
but the problem now is you've got people
saying curtail the use of our most
efficient form of energy so far okay
well then all people are gonna die
yeah and and that is the adult
conversation we need to have
um there is no perfect fuel source i
wish there was there's no perfect energy
source i wish there were but
but i'm not plato right it is not me
versus this ideal
we have to live in the in the reality
and the reality is
everything has its drawbacks but for the
price point
for the efficiency and for the quality
of life we demand and this is
my biggest argument when it comes to the
fossil fuel industry and getting rid of
it is
that is where they want to sacrifice
cost does it matter doesn't matter if we
pay what germany pays
efficiency doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if we can't store the electricity
that's why you hear authoritarians say
well
kamala harris was asked should we talk
about dietary regulations and she said
you know i think we should have a
conversation about that let's talk about
those cheeseburgers
the government's going to regulate our
food of course they don't send no more
meat
bill gates also bought the most amount
of farmland than anyone else in the
united states specifically because he
wants everyone to eat
fake meat live in the pot and eat the
bugs absolutely
there are a class of people that think
that they have the authority over us to
to determine the quality of life we
wanted i think that that is how you
really get a revolution that is how you
get bloodshed
i would like to point out though i
actually
think that the idea of having a pod is
pretty cool just as
we're talking about in the middle of the
woods get my own little place got my own
little
little little home that's what i'm doing
oh yeah yeah and another thing too is
the
other thing too is i i see this meme
it's like i will not live in the pot
when i eat the bugs and i'm kind of like
why is it bad to eat bugs like i i look
there's
where's that like 85 percent of the
planet eats bugs you don't have to eat
bugs if you don't want to that's
i think it's fair if you say i don't
want any bugs i'll buy that's cool i
don't eat bugs
but i'm also kind of like foods food but
like lobsters or bugs
big insects another thing
we have to kind of comprehend here is
that bill gates
invests his money into specifically
creating fake meat
he then goes on 60 minutes and anderson
cooper is like wow
this is such a great idea i love this
idea
as he's promoting fake meat he has no
fat in it that's
the problem there's a lot of problems
surrounding this especially genetically
modified food which bill gates has
extensive ties to especially to
corporations like monsanto
that have a horrendous human rights
record that have a horrendous record of
of
actively knowingly hurting people and
still doing it for profit
i just think the idea that the second or
third richest person in the world
whatever he is today he's second or
third
and a vanderbilt heir sat down together
and they talked about the sacrifices we
have to make
a millionaire and a billionaire deciding
what we should what sacrifices
we're going to and a republic is a
well-armed populist contesting that vote
holy cow
like that's some that's some scary stuff
right there yeah i don't want to be part
of that world i'm
like the little mermaid i don't want to
be part of your world
i want to we we talked about the the
great reset
you're familiar with i'm sure yeah and
scary a lot of people are wondering if
they're doing it on purpose and i'm like
listen we don't need to ask what they're
doing on purpose what they're doing is
in effect creating
the great race that they've talked about
so you want to get conspiratorial you
can find
we don't have to be we just say i don't
i don't care what their intention is the
result is this great reset
they're locking us down they say it's
for the pandemic sure this is what's
happening
now that being said part of me you know
because
we had we had jack murphy on the show
and i mentioned they want people to live
kind of you know more in the country and
more back to nature
like chopping rolling up their sleeves
and chopping their own lumber and
and jack was like what's wrong with that
so there's a part of this where it's
like listen
i believe in freedom if you want to eat
your burger with with
ketchup schlopp all over it or whatever
you like on your burger mayo pickles
lettuce you know cheese or whatever you
go ahead and do it i however think
there's a lot to be gained
from regular people who are addicted to
this system
getting out learning how to work going
to the woods
actually learning how to raise chickens
raise raise uh
meat pig cow or whatever and just being
responsible for themselves for once in
their lives
too many americans are gluttonous
living in big cities demanding the
government do the work or or take the
labor from other people to pay for them
yeah they're not you're absolutely right
um
i am born and raised in new york city i
lived in dc for a very very long time
i have a year now my my fiancee and i
uh got a little farm and where where
uh chicken sheep turkeys peacocks aren't
chickens awesome i love them yeah
they're they're fun
what do the peacocks do uh they're full
they make noise they make a lot of noise
they are ultimately for profit
can you sell them we will we bought them
as eggs and we will sell them you know
like really rich people we're the
poorest people in town
really rich people will want them for
their lawn to walk around and strut like
flannery o'connor amazing so we'll sign
to you at
three years of age you do have pea hens
as well we have
uh the females yes and they lay eggs you
eat the eggs
um they're not old enough yet to lay
eggs uh well
i mean hopefully the eggs will be
fertilized and we'll have more of them
do you have uh roosters for your
chickens i
have too many roosters and aren't they
hilarious
they are and they're there it can be
very mean yeah i know but it's really
funny but
it's just running like yelling at you
and you're got scrapes all over me
but but the point i was gonna make is i
was that dc
a feat you know like like going to
brunch and getting a reservation was the
big thing
and you didn't do manual labor and i
have for the last year
and this goes back to benjamin franklin
and thomas jefferson who argued how it
was man better but it goes back to lock
and hops it goes back to plato aristotle
where is mankind better situated and i
have been thinking a lot about how i do
feel like a better human being because i
have to
make fence posts and i have to mend
things and i get dirty and i have to
play with chicken feces and
it's gross and it's work and it's labor
and you
and it's freezing cold and you have a
hangover and and you smoke too much the
night before and your lungs are killing
you but the animals need to eat and
they're in the barn and they are
hungry and and it does make you a better
per i am a better person in the country
i really are a great feeling
from eating your own home-grown eggs yes
it's very it's very so amazing so when i
lived in miami we had chickens
and i'd go out in the morning i'd grab a
couple of the eggs bring them back in
and i would i would bake with that yeah
it was it was awesome i was like this is
so cool
these things are out in my yard like
eating bugs and they poop these things
out and i
put my pancakes it's great now i have a
leg up though for anyone who's watching
the show
who's like uh oh so i can start a farm
my fiance
is a legit uh aussie outback
cowboy who grew up on 25 000 acres and
he did this his whole life
so i had some i had cheating
a couple sheep and chickens like this
isn't i had you know 5 000 head of
cattle in my on my
wow on my ranch um so so i have a leg up
but still it's a great
it makes you a better person it's fun
and it's exciting and it's different and
you learn so much and you learn so much
about life i lived on a pig farm this
summer uh
very gratifying it smelled a little bit
but but i learned
a lot of really interesting things about
nature and how the
world works that you would never
understand in a big city and you know
what we have is a couple of
sign interrupts we have a we have all
heritage breeds which you who
talked a couple of times about gmos
right
there are these breeds that that are
dying and we're trying to we're doing
our little part to save them because
we have cross bred them so many times
for meat for
for large breasted chicken for fattier
pigs so we have all heritage breeds and
they're not as pretty they're maybe not
as tasty they're not as
but they're but they're awful and
they're real and they're
fun-looking they're funny-looking
they're kind of ugly yeah they're just
people need to understand the genetic
splicing and the genetic
kind of larger kind of organizations
that that are putting together these
wild experiments
are absolutely mind-boggling and scary
to say the least
my friend accidentally became a pig
farmer um because the government said
kill all the pigs right when kovet hid
they were like well you know rather be
safe than sorry kill all of them he went
to a local farm picked him up
illegally and then brought him to his
farm and
then we learned like oh yeah these are
you know specifically bred
pigs just to get fat they're they're not
to run
they're just going to be sitting here
and eating and that's it here's the
question i have for your you know your
average rural living conservative
wouldn't you like
for just once in their lives these urban
liberals to understand why
you need a weapon why you need a gun
when you're out in the middle of nowhere
and you've got some animals and you're
worried about feral hogs or you're
worried about coyotes coyotes and you
gotta protect those you care about not
just your animals but your family
wouldn't you want them to experience for
once in their life why they have to chop
lumber
why they have to go out and make sure
they get enough wood for the for the
stove
because you're not going to have
necessarily the propane delivery in time
if the if the roads are slicked up
wouldn't you just want them to
experience hard work the problem is
well it's i think it sounds good
teaching people responsibility
getting them out to go you know actually
learn how to survive and be responsible
for themselves
the people who are orchestrating these
big changes the people who are calling
for these changes
don't want people to actually be freed
independent yeah they're advocating for
taking away the weapons of these
individuals
and i know a lot of people say tim the
second amendment isn't about hunting and
stuff like i i know i know it's
literally about securing a free state
but one of the biggest reasons anybody
would need to know how and be trained
with a weapon is
you've got to protect your home you live
in the middle of nowhere where you don't
got cops
but more importantly you hear the
coyotes out in the back and what happens
when they come for your chickens
you pepper them up with some birdchat or
something scare them away or whatever it
is you do
or even feral hogs when they come they
come in large droves they come in large
numbers and
a high capacity magazine is something
you're going to need having a 10 round
magazine sometimes won't suffice and
will you'll have in danger you'll have
to have a bunch of magazines well even
then reloading and loading
takes a while and during stressful
situations people mess that up
so so again it's nonsensical and it's
going to hurt people on so many
different levels and and you bring up
very important points i try to shame the
coyotes into not doing it
i give them bad reviews i tweet negative
things you try to cancel them i do
yeah so like shame on you and i take
pictures and i tell them
you know we're gonna kick them out but
you're gonna tell their boss on them
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you